♪ ♪
>> Juan: IF YOU THOUGHT THE
TWITTER FEUD BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
KELLYANNE CONWAY'S HUSBAND WAS
GOING AWAY ANYTIME SOON, THINK
AGAIN.
GEORGE CONWAY RE-TWEETING ALL
KINDS OF NEW ATTACKS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT TODAY, INCLUDING
SUGGESTING THAT TRUMP IS
MENTALLY UNSTABLE.
THIS COMES AS KELLYANNE CONWAY
IS ONCE AGAIN SIDING WITH HER
BOSS OVER HER HUSBAND.
>> MY HUSBAND ALSO HAS BEEN VERY
CRITICAL OF THE PRESIDENT
PUBLICLY WHICH IS NONE LIKE HIM
JUST BECAUSE HE'S TRADITIONALLY
BEEN A VERY PRIVATE PERSON.
IN 2016, YEAR OF THE TWEET,
GEORGE CONWAY SENT ZERO TWEETS.
THIS IS NEW.
WHAT ALSO IS NEW IS NOT
SUPPORTING THE AGENDA OF THE
PRESIDENT AND MY WORK THERE.
I WAS RAISED IN A HOUSEHOLD OF
STRONG ITALIAN CATHOLIC WOMAN
WHO TAUGHT ME THAT YOU AIR
GRIEVANCES LIKE THAT IN PRIVATE.
IT'S VERY SURPRISING TO SEE IT
BE SO PUBLIC.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Juan: IT'S SO INTERESTING
TO ME.
WE SHOULD START A SHOW.
USE OF THIS YESTERDAY, CALLED
THE CONWAYS.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IF IT'S REAL, WHAT KELLYANNE
SAID TO MARIA BARTIROMO WAS
SHE'S NEVER REALLY ADDRESS THIS
WITH HER HUSBAND.
THEY'VE ONLY TALKED ABOUT IN
PASSING.
MEANWHILE, GEORGE CONWAY SAYS HE
GETS TO TWEETING SO HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO SCREAM AT HIS WIFE.
>> Emily: IN MY NOTES FOR THIS
BLOCK, I DREW A DUMPSTER FIRE.
I THINK IT WOULD PROBABLY BE
BEST IF SOMEONE DOESN'T WANT THE
TOPIC TO BE COVERED THAT THEY
REFRAIN FROM SPEAKING ABOUT IT.
THE MORE CONTENT PUT OUT BY ALL
THREE OF THOSE PARTIES IS
UNFORTUNATE AND IT'S DISTRACTING
FROM LARGER ISSUES AT HAND AND
ALSO THEIR CREDIBILITY.
>> Juan: JESSE COME HE'S HAS
SOME REALLY STRONG THINGS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT.
WHACK JOB.
HE'S A NARCISSIST.
ANTISOCIAL.
HE PUTS OUT ALL KINDS OF
PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSES FOR PEOPLE
TO READ ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
AND I JUST WONDER HOW DOES THIS
IMPACT PEOPLE WHO ARE TRUMP
FANS.
WHAT DO THEY THINK?
>> Jesse: HE SHOULD LOOK IN
THE MIRROR.
TALK ABOUT PSYCHOLOGICAL
IMBALANCE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS GUY IS UP
TO.
I LIKE YOUR NEW HEAD MOVEMENTS
THIS WEEK, VERY BETA-ESQUE.
NEVER SEEN YOU.
>> Greg: I THINK IT'S CALLED
MILKING THE GOAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: LIKE EMILY, I DON'T
HAVE A LOT TO SAY ABOUT THEIR
MATE -- THEIR MARRIAGE.
IT'S A PRIVATE MATTER.
I WOULD SAY KELLYANNE CONWAY IS
HANDLING IT GRACEFULLY.
I HATE TO SEE YOU'RE EMBARRASSED
BY THIS.
IT LOOKS LIKE GEORGE MIGHT HAVE
TRUMPED DERANGEMENT SYNDROME AND
MAYBE HE'S ANGLING FOR A CNN
CONTRIBUTOR SHIP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
I KIND OF DON'T WANT TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON AND I HOPE WE
CAN ALL MOVE ON.
>> Juan: DANA, AS THIS IS
TAKING PLACE, THE PRESIDENT'S
FEUD WITH THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
OVER JOHN McCAIN CONTINUES AND
IT'S ALMOST LIKE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING WELL, WE DON'T LIKE THAT.
>> Dana: I THINK THE
PRESIDENT'S FEUD IS WITH
JOHN McCAIN AND THERE HAVE
BEEN -- I DON'T THINK OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND NOT FEUDING WITH THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THAT.
SOME OF THEM LIKE CONGRESSMAN
DAN CRENSHAW ARE SAYING PLEASE,
MR. PRESIDENT, STOP IT.
HE'S NOT EUROPE LOCAL ENEMY.
MOVE ON.
ON THE CONWAY STUFF, ONE THING I
THINK ABOUT THIS IS I AGREE, I
KIND OF WISH WE DIDN'T KNOW BUT
HERE'S THE THING.
GEORGE CONWAY WANTS US TO KNOW
THIS.
HE IS POKING THE BEAR.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND TO WHAT
DESIRED OUTCOME.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO HAPPEN.
YOU'RE NOT THE FIRST TO SAY THE
PRESIDENT HAS NARCISSISTIC
PERSONALITY DISORDER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT NO ONE
ELSE IS ABLE TO DO BY SAYING THE
SAME THING?
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
DO YOU WANT TO MAKE LIFE HARDER
FOR YOUR WIFE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE?
DO YOU THINK IT DOESN'T AFFECT
HER AT THE WHITE HOUSE?
DO YOU WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
PAINT YOU AS A WORSE HUSBAND
THAN HE?
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE SITUATION.
I WISH WE COULD JUST NOT TALK
ABOUT IT.
>> Juan: I THINK HE SAID HE
WOULD LIKE HER TO STOP, TO LEAVE
THE JOB.
>> Dana: I MUST'VE MISSED
THAT.
>> Greg: I DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I LOVE EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
>> Dana: I KNOW YOU DO.
>> Greg: WAS INTERESTING, WE
TALK ABOUT IT BEING LIKE A
REALITY SHOW.
TRUMP HAS BEEN ABLE TO COMBINE A
WHOLE BUNCH OF DIFFERENT SHOWS.
IT'S LIKE A SOAP OPERA WITH A
LOT OF SUBPLOTS.
SICA VERSION OF FALCON CREST.
FIRST TRUMP IS JR EWING.
BUT THEN PENCE IS NED FLANDERS.
MATLOCK.
KELLYANNE AND HER HUSBAND COULD
BE LIKE FROM THREES COMPANY BUT
HE IS MORE LIKE NEWMAN AND BRIAN
STELTER'S COUSIN IS CAN
STANDS.
THIS WAS GOING ON FOR A WHILE.
IT'S KIND OF MOVING TOWARDS A
RESOLUTION AND I'M -- I CAN'T
WAIT TO SEE WHAT IT IS.
HOW IT'S GOING TO END.
IT'S LIKE WHO SHOT JR.
WE ARE GETTING TO A CLIMAX.
>> Jesse: SEASON FINALE.
>> Greg: WE NEED MORE OF
THESE.
>> Dana: MAY BE AS A FINALE
WILL WAKE UP AND FIND OUT IT WAS
A DREAM.